charité
[Musique]
Je continue à vouloir dire chasité
oh ouais
c'est possible
de sortir de la vie
euh
que tu le vaux bien peu importe ce que
tu as vécu et à quoi ça ressemble
euh qu'il y a de l'espoir
si je ne pouvais pas le montrer  plus de charité honnêtement
fausse
euh
mon père qui est décédé et moi juste
quelques mois quelques mois mais nous avons
fait plusieurs événements maintenant chaque fois que nous faisons
des événements, vous savez, j'étais un peu
ignorant avant de me rencontrer quand j'ai entendu parler du
trafic sexuel  Je me dis oh, ce
n'est pas ici, c'est dans un
autre pays ou autre, alors pour
découvrir que cela se passe dans notre propre
jardin, mon cœur s'est brisé, alors
euh alors ouais, quand elle a dit que tu savais qu'ils avaient
ces tatouages ​​de marque que tu sais
si vous voulez, faites don d'un peu de
votre temps et de vos efforts et
aidez à redonner à ces femmes leur corps, j'ai
dit 100 100
.
[Musique]
Je dirais que la chose la plus importante
que j'ai apprise, c'est
que je vaux la peine d'être sauvée, tu
sais, pendant longtemps, je ne
croyais pas que j'aimais, j'ai dit que je
pensais que j'avais mérité les choses
qui se sont produites,
tu sais et  tout au long de mon parcours de guérison, j'ai
appris que cela n'était pas censé
arriver, que cela n'aurait pas dû arriver,
que je ne le méritais pas et que je valais la peine d'être
sauvé.